question politique
Thomas negarov bonjour Marc feno bonjour
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire pour commencer
je vous pose d'écouter un maire qui ne
l'est plus Yannick Mahrez le maire
démissionnaire de Saint-Brévin qui
jettent l'éponge après les violences des
opposants à sa politique d'accueil des
migrants on a l'impression dans le pays
un petit peu tous ces frites au niveau
de tous les services publics que ce soit
la justice que ce soit l'éducation que
ce soit la santé j'en sais ce qui est
quelque chose puisque je suis médecin
généraliste tous ces gros services
publics en fin de compte commencent à
diminuer à être plus du tout à la
hauteur en fin de compte de ce que les
habitants n'attendent et en fait ça fait
peur ils vont s'aperçoit que la violence
entre temps et bien pendant ce temps-là
augmente les extrêmes augmentent et on
peut se poser des questions quand même
pour l'avenir notamment pour nos enfants
inquiet qui démissionne un médecin qui
quitte son emploi qui quitte sa ville
qui déménage harcelé sa maison brûlée
comment l'élu de la République que vous
avez longtemps été réag et que je suis
responsive municipal bah il réagit comme
un comme un ancien maire et comme un élu
municipal que je suis sur la pression
que Sully subissent les élus locaux que
subissent les élus tout court et sur la
nécessité que nous avons dans le débat
public au-delà du cas de ce monsieur qui
est un cas terrible parce que c'est à la
fois un cas de harcèlement à quelqu'un
qui est conduit à non seulement
démissionner son poste mais aussi à
quitter sa ville
grande responsabilité de ceux qui ont
attisé
la haine la querelle sur le projet qui
était porté par ce maire et par ce
conseil municipal dans sa vie j'entends
monsieur Zemmour aujourd'hui nous
expliquer qu'il faut appeler à
l'apaisement quand il y a un mois ou
deux mois il appelait à faire des
manifestations et à s'opposer à ce
projet de façon très élément en tout cas
par la voix et par le verbe je dis
souvent cela j'ai longtemps que vous
m'avez entendu le dire je dis souvent le
verbe précède les actes et attention
toujours dans le débat public et puis
par ailleurs dans globalement quand on a
un désaccord avec quelqu'un sur tel ou
tel projet sur tel ou telle chose à
faire attention à ce que les mots ne
provoquent pas à la fin la violence
la violence réelle la violence verbale
pour moi elle est souvent la
préfiguration de la violence réelle et
donc ici qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
contre les mouvements d'extrême droite
qui souffle effectivement sur les
braises il y a le mouvement la
manifestement c'est plutôt autour des
mouvements d'instagrades d'ailleurs il y
a une enquête qui est en cours sur la
question de l'incendie qui a été
provoquée sur des voitures qui ont
provoqué un incendie sur la maison donc
la justice doit faire son œuvre
s'enfléchir mais j'ai aucun doute
là-dessus globalement qu'est-ce qu'on
doit faire pour faire en sorte que des
mouvements qui prônent la violence
d'extrême droite ou ailleurs il y a des
mouvements aussi d'extrême gauche qui
creusent pour la volance et parfois les
interdictions qui ont été
prodigués on voit bien que parfois il y
a aussi des limites parce qu'il y a
aussi l'état de droit qui doit
s'appliquer c'est normal sur
l'expression de la liberté il y a aussi
des dissolutions d'associations qui ont
été qui ont été faites par le sur
proposition du ministre de l'Intérieur
je pense aux oies en particulier alors
après les mouvements se reconstituent
enfin c'est une lutte sans relâche et
puis il y a dans nos attitudes je le
répète collectivement nous devons faire
en sorte que c'est pas parce qu'on
aimait réconforte un projet c'est pas
parce qu'on est agriculteur et qu'on a
un projet c'est pas parce qu'on est
bouché mais simplement parce qu'on est
bouché on prend le risque de simplement
exercer une activité c'est pas parce
qu'on est député qu'on doit être menacé
ou qu'on doit montrer sa tête et donner
des adresses pour au fond inciter à
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre du
passage à l'acte et n'oublie pas que les
gens de la recherche de la cause ou des
auteurs de ce de cette chose lamentable
est-ce que il y a pas quelque chose
à m'installation des cases sur le fond
en gros c'est qui un certain nombre de
lieux dans lequel on va installer les
personnes qui sont en demande de papier
est-ce que on peut pas aller plus
expliquer la population mieux choisir
mieux associer les gens de manière
surtout à diminuer là donc c'est les
centres d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
on avait raison de le préciser de sortir
de l'acronyme mais oui vous avez raison
mais sur sur l'ensemble des projets on a
ces difficultés là et donc on a besoin
de reconstruire quelque chose d'un lien
d'un dialogue d'un débat démocratique
qui soit plus simple parce que ce que
vous dites sur les cadavres c'est
valable sur des tas de projets
aujourd'hui en France vous avez une
implantation d'une autoroute vous avez
de la violence qui s'exprime et des gens
qui viennent s'y opposer par des actes
de violence vous avez des sujets on va
peut-être en parler autour de l'eau
c'est la même chose c'est le même nature
pour vous les violences d'extrême gauche
et d'extrême droite moi je ne qualifie
pas politiquement la violence la
violence et la violence
d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême droite ou
d'extrême centre qui vous permettez
cette expression jamais n'accepter la
violence il n'y a pas une bonne et une
mauvaise violence ce n'est pas accepter
des sujets qui sont un petit peu
différents
quand on commence à dire il y a des
sujets qui sont différents ça voudrait
dire si je poursuis je n'ai pas dit que
vous avez dit ça qui aurait des sujets
qui justifierait de la violence il y a
aucun sujet qui justifie de la violence
faite un tiers jamais
d'écoute donc c'est ce que je vous fais
pour éviter non mais je tire la pelote
de ce que vous dites parce que je le
répète si vous commencez à dire il y a
des sujets plus ou moins graves en
termes de violence sur les personnes et
des violences qui ne sont pas sur les
personnes quant au bout
il y a des violences sur les personnes
je condamne les violences sur les
personnes quel que soit les violences y
compris
il dit aussi qui manque de soutien
politique puisqu'il démissionne après un
mois après avoir alerté tout le monde et
d'avoir reçu aucune aide à la deuxième
partie de votre question mais je ne
pouvais pas laisser passer l'idée qu'il
y aurait des bonnes et des mauvaises
violences selon la cause physique
deuxième élément on a besoin ça fait
quoi ce que vous avez dit on a besoin de
construire sur les projets et nous
sommes un pays qui a quand même une
culture conflictuelle on a besoin de
mieux accompagner globalement alors ici
c'est parfois l'état là c'est parfois la
collectivité là c'est parfois l'État et
la collectivité enfin bref c'est parfois
le tissu associatif on a besoin de mieux
expliquer ce que sont les projets ce que
sont leurs périmètre voire de voter non
de voir des référendum pour savoir si on
fait si on est dans un pays alors je
sais que attendez on peut se demander
notre dame de langues
j'essaie de répondre à votre question on
peut se poser la question de voter mais
si vous voyez bien que sur chaque projet
que nous implantons en France quel que
soit la nature du projet on vote ça veut
dire qu'il y a plus de démocratie
représentative et qui a plus besoin
d'élus les élus et j'en suis un local
ils sont là pour prendre des
responsabilités doit apporter l'exécutif
comment les aider
comment on arrive à mieux encore
structurer le réseau de vigilance quand
ta mère est en difficulté moi j'ai connu
personnellement j'ai des adjoints dans
ma commune qui se font insultés menacées
de mort bon c'est des choses qui sont
très courantes malheureusement et donc
il faut un que la parole se libère parce
que souvent que moi quand ça m'est
arrivé je suis pas passé à la
gendarmerie pour aller raconter je l'ai
dit comme ça au gendarme j'ai pas été
porté plainte tout ça va s'apaiser on a
besoin quand même que ce réseau
vigilance qui est le quotidien de
beaucoup d'élus s'active c'est à dire le
réseau des gendarmes qui le font hein
très régulièrement que la justice et
c'est des instructions qui ont été
données de ce point de vue là pour faire
en sorte qu'elle soit plus sévère avec
des actes y compris des actes de menaces
verbales qui sont des actes
préfigurateurs comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure et puis troisième élément on a
besoin de construire avec les élus
locaux ça a été fait d'ailleurs je le
rappelle maintenant les associations
d'élus peuvent se porter partie civiles
et peuvent agir en justice pour le
compte d'un élu qui parfois n'osent pas
donc on a besoin de ça premier élément
c'est que la justice l'État de droit
soit respecté donc les services de
l'État en territoire soit soit aux côtés
depuis deux quand on a un projet qui
nécessite de la conflictualité on a
besoin de mieux armées au bon au sens et
intellectuel du terme vous l'imaginez
bien de mieux armer les élus pour
demandez-nous la conflictualité j'ai
toujours été frappé quand on porte des
projets des fois c'est ça
les mouvements d'extrême droite dont on
parlait tout à l'heure sur un sujet
d'immigration dont effectivement
il redonnez-moi je vais finir aussi on a
quand même le sentiment que cette
bataille idéologique sur l'immigration
l'extrême droite est en train de gagner
et qu'on n'ose pas je suis je suis pas
sûr de ça c'est pour ça prolonger ce
matin un maire de l'Indre raconte que
j'ai vu voilà dans sa commune il y a à
peu près les mêmes types de
problématiques que dans la rue que que
Saint-Brevin et il dit sur le terrain il
y a énormément de militants de
reconquête du rassemblement national et
sous-entendu il y a un vide aussi
politique laissé par des gens par
exemple de la majorité est-ce que vous
entendez ça aussi Laurent Berger c'est
un autre domaine mais qui dit
aujourd'hui à la santé des usines les
gens qui tractent c'est le RN est-ce que
vous avez ce sentiment d'avoir aussi un
peu peut-être abandonné le terrain mais
enfin collectivement enfin je veux bien
prendre ma part j'ai pas de difficulté
non non mais je quand je dis je veux
bien mettre un nous sommes
collectivement responsables de ne pas
arriver toujours à essayer sur le
terrain d'expliciter de dialoguer de
faire en sorte sur les projets comme
vous l'avez évoqué il y a des
territoires des choses se sont plutôt
bien passées
alors il y a parfois des territoires il
y a plus de conflits que d'autres c'est
difficile de voir comment fonctionne les
écosystèmes souvent ce sont des
militants d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas du
territoire et compris dans la commune
que vous évoquez c'est-à-dire des gens
qui ne sont pas de ce territoire qui
viennent parce qu'ils viennent en faire
un lieu symbolique il y a aussi quelque
chose il faut que les habitants se
saisissent de leur sujet et que nous
nous les accompagnons mais que nous
ayons besoin collectivement comme nous
dit Laurent Berger de nous ressaisir de
cette question et de ne pas laisser
prospérer le terrain de la haine où les
terrains de la du populisme et de la
démagogie je pense que c'est l'oeuvre
que nous devons porter tous ceux de la
majorité comme ceux de l'opposition que
je crois être dans le champ républicain
qui doivent eux aussi apporter leur pire
à l'édifice ils sont dans l'opposition
j'en demande pas d'aller dans la
majorité ils ont on a besoin
collectivement de travailler sur ces
sujets on voit bien que ces sujets
complexes très voilà on a besoin de
travailler sur ces sujets ça veut dire
on dit quoi on affronte on a besoin de
on a besoin de ces cadenas on a besoin
de ces centres parce qu'on a des
demandeurs d'asile on a besoin de
traiter leurs dossier on a besoin de
lieu où ils soient hébergé dans des
conditions dignes ça sent pas suffire à
convaincre la population qui s'inquiète
de plus en plus de l'arrivée de réfugiés
on a tous un discours qu'on entend pas
du tout excusez-moi
je vous dis qu'on a besoin de mieux dire
vous me demandez ce qu'on fait je vous
dis qu'on a besoin de mieux dire ce que
sont les cadas quoi il sert en quoi ça
relève quand même de la plus élémentaire
dignité qu'on doit aux personnes qui
sont demandeurs d'asile et dont on doit
examiner les cas et en quoi les endroits
on a besoin de montrer que dans les
endroits où il y a des cadas aujourd'hui
il y a pas de difficultés majeures qui
comment vous les choisissez Oui mais
c'est que ce soit parce que le projet au
début il est bien passé
Bernard Cazeneuve d'essayer de faire un
dispatching pour pas avoir des
concentrations et d'ailleurs le cas de
l'Indre il y a c'est 38 migrants je
crois ou 28
c'est une trentaine mais est-ce que l'on
doit pas toujours l'obsession associer
les gens et dire les critères pourquoi
les gens c'est dans telle commune je
vais dans votre sens je ne peux pas
mieux vous dire que ce que je vous dis
c'est à dire de dire il faut qu'on
explique sur ces projets là qui sont les
plus parfois un source de conflictualité
il faut que collectivement ceux qui sont
des responsables publics responsables si
je peux dire cette phrase comme ça et
des gens qui dansent en républicains
savent que il y a des sujets à traiter
qu'il faut aller sur traiter avec
sérieux pas de démagogie et donc on a
besoin de territoire par territoire de
se dire ici on a besoin de ce type de
centre ici on a besoin de traiter comme
ça les choses pour avancer pour clore ce
chapitre le maire de Saint-Brévin évoque
aussi le manque de soutien de la part de
l'État on a aussi aujourd'hui des
dossiers dans la presse quotidienne
régionale qui mettent en avant beaucoup
de maire qui sont qui se sentent un peu
isolées un peu oubliés est-ce que vous
entendez ça et comment est-ce qu'on dit
d'abord il faut l'entendre parce que au
nord de l'entendre ce que je veux dire
c'est sentiment ou réalité il faut
l'entendre parce que quand vous vous
sentez sentiment était bien soutenu je
vous dis
sentimentalité oui mais j'essaie de
répondre parce que c'est des sujets qui
sont importants ce que je pense que
c'est des sujets très toxiques pour la
République
les sujets où la violence vient
s'imposer ou quelqu'un est appelé à
déménager vous imaginez pas mais c'est
pas seulement une démission parce que
des mères qui démissionnent sur des
projets qui ont généré la conflictualité
et compris dans leur conseil ça a déjà
existé mais qui viennent à quitter le
lieu de résidence parce qu'ils se
sentent menacés et détesté par une
partie de gens qui sont dans leur
territoire ça c'est un problème très
grave c'est pour ça que ça mérite ce
temps là donc on a besoin sans doute
d'une plus grande attention je suis pas
sûr que je sais pas si dans ce cas là
particulièrement mais il y a besoin
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
d'une forme de chaîne qui doit se
consolider entre les forces de police et
le gendarmerie la justice les élus
eux-mêmes entre eux et nous-mêmes dans
nos prises de parole de faire en sorte
que nous fassions attention à ne pas
exacerber les passions
France Inter
[Musique]
hashtag question Paul Marc feno ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire l'un des enjeux pour nous
nous tous ici un consommateur c'est
évidemment combien on paye quand on veut
se nourrir qui est quand même une
activité nécessaire pour notre survie
c'est un sujet essentiel que l'inflation
il y en a un qui a une solution clé en
main c'est pas n'importe qui c'est
Michel Édouard Leclerc on l'écoute donc
ce qu'on va aller chercher c'est des
prix plus bas c'est des rabais des
remises Leclerc va faire le tour de
l'Europe pour aller chercher ce qui est
de moins cher partout en Europe on a des
Leclerc en Pologne on a des Leclerc au
Portugal l'idole est pareil en Allemagne
et tout ça et c'est et c'est mais on
demande que la loi française nous
autorise à faire ça et donc il faut que
les ministres d'aller chercher des
produits moins chers au-delà de la
promesse au-delà de nous accompagner et
nous nous faire rencontrer les
industriels il faut qu'il nous donne le
cadre juridique qui nous autorise le
renégocier de dossier des prix de
renégocier des prix à la baisse c'est du
bon sens alors je sais pas si c'est du
bon sens c'est d'abord ça me paraît
assez caricatural alors ça pose
plusieurs c'est le problème au moins
j'en vois deux le premier c'est qu'il y
a une loi française donc au fond ce que
nous propose monsieur Leclerc c'est de
contourner la loi française bah c'est
rien d'autre que ça qui propose c'est
quand même un peu gênant
contourner la loi
c'est quand même puis deuxièmement enfin
il demande pas il veut pas contourner la
loi il demande d'améliorer les choses ou
de changer les choses déjà qui va être
hors la loi j'ai pas envie d'en faire
une querelle avec Michel Édouard Leclerc
pour tout vous dire mais allons-y
puisque c'est lui qui pose ses questions
là il a été opposé depuis le début à la
loi egalim considère que le meilleur
prix c'était le prix payer le moins cher
au producteur résultat des courses on a
perdu un souveraineté alors si la
politique de Michel-Edouard Leclerc
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on perd en
souvanté et qu'on détruise l'agriculture
française il faut qu'il l'assume mais
moi je considère que quand on a une
entreprise française qu'on a des
salariés français qu'on a des
consommateurs français que on a des
agriculteurs français on doit porter une
part de patriotisme il me semble
considérait qu'il fait défaut comment
vous considérez qu'il fait des fois en
disant ça il me semble que il est en
faisant ce qu'il fait en faisant ce
qu'il fait surtout en disant là ce que
ce qu'il exprime c'est au fond j'irai
chercher des produits à l'extérieur
poussant la logique jusqu'au bout plus
personne ne va acheter des produits
français dans les dans les supermarchés
plus personne ne s'approvisionne donc
très rapidement il y a plus
l'agriculture française et dans 5 ans
quand on a une grande crise qu'est-ce
qu'il ira faire il ira chercher à
l'extérieur des frontières et donc on se
rend en situation de dépendance et de
d'absolu dépendance comme le soin un
certain nombre de bruit pas le risque
comprendre en étant mais je sais que
vous partagez mais j'imagine que vous
partagez le risque qu'on prend en
expliquant qu'à la vérité pourrait mieux
aller chercher parce que pourquoi il ira
en Europe à ce moment-là il faut qu'il
pousse sa logique le plus loin possible
faut qu'il aille dans des pays qui ne
respectent aucune de nos normes
environnementales qui n'ont pas notre
même modèle social et là il aura les
prix des produits
non mais poussons la logique
parce que si la logique c'est je veux
avoir les prix les plus bas pourquoi ça
s'arrêterait aux frontières de l'Europe
ce que vous dites ce que vous dites
fondamentalement aussi ça veut dire ce
qu'on peut aujourd'hui acheter des
produits à des prix abordables tout en
respectant les contrats écologiques et
sociales et comment faire pour respecter
le l'agriculteur et et respecter aussi
les clones
c'est l'extrême tension dans laquelle on
est en particulier dans ce moment un
flashmitt quand il y avait pas
d'inflation qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pendant 10 ans ceux qui viennent
maintenant sur les antennes dire ce
genre de propos ils ont fait de la
déflation agricole résultat des courses
on est à 50% autosuffisant au fruits et
légumes ça ce qui s'est passé non
l'inflation est un sujet pour les
Français ne l'instrumentalisons pas
d'une politique qui doute date depuis
10-15 ou 20 ans pourquoi on est pas là
juste pour qu'on comprenne tous pourquoi
on est plus cher que les autres pourquoi
quand on va au marché et toi que tout ce
qui est espagnol par exemple sur les
poivrons sur le tout ce qui vient de
d'ailleurs et moins cher qu'une pardon
ça n'est pas exactement
comment
je réponds aux questions
qu'on avec les Espagnols de la saison
parce que
le deuxième élément pardon c'est
étonnant que pourquoi quand vous
regardez la culbute qui est fait sur les
fruits et légumes elle est si forte sur
les fruits et légumes et moins forte sur
d'autres produits de grande consommation
y compris des produits qui sont en
situation monopolistique pourquoi parce
que la marge est beaucoup plus grande
là-dessus et donc il y a aussi une part
que j'ai souvent souligné auprès de la
grande distribution qu'une part d'effort
pour faire en sorte que les marches
soient pas là les plus fortes sauf que
évidemment c'est plus facile d'aller
négocier avec un producteur tout seul
qu'avec négocié avec un grand groupe les
distributeurs profitent en ce moment de
l'inflation je n'ai pas dit que non je
dis pas ça
horreur de cette thèse de les un profil
parle de profiteur effectivement non on
va reprendre pardon je réponds à votre
question
dans le même au même moment si je peux
essayer de répondre donc on a un sujet
parfois de compétitivité en particulier
sur les fruits et légumes c'est pour ça
qu'on a besoin d'investir de moderniser
de consolider les outils de baisse de
charge comme l'a fait le président de la
République compétitivité pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est coûte cher dans la main
d'oeuvre et ce qu'on a trop de
contraintes écolières il y a la part de
la main d'oeuvre il y a sans doute le
fait que la rémunération ayant été trop
faible depuis 10 ans sur un site de
récupérer un peu on n'a pas été capable
de réinvestir et donc de gagner en
compétitivité ça c'est un élément
important il y a parfois une forme de
surademnistration mais ça n'est pas une
question seulement de norme c'est une
question de surandemnistration quand
vous voulez développer un projet c'est
plus compliqué en France qu'ailleurs et
par ailleurs on a besoin de penser notre
marché c'est à dire de dire à quel
moment en particulier je reprends sur
les fruits et légumes à quel moment on
arrive sur le marché parce qu'on voit
bien qu'il y a une forme de saisonnalité
et à quel moment c'est le mieux pour les
produits français d'arriver en
saisonnalité et on a besoin d'une grande
distribution pardon qui met en valeur
les produits français or aujourd'hui
vous savez très bien à quel point dans
un état quand vous mettez en valeur ou
plus ou moins un produit vous le vendez
plus ou moins et comment mais pourquoi
ils font ça pourquoi il faut ça
non mais il y a une partie qui a été
faite sur la sur les fruits et légumes
qui une partie de marge qui sont parfois
trop élevées vous regardez la vous
pouvez pas dire quand même que ils s'en
mettent par les poches
économique
de vous dire qu'il s'en met plein les
poches
on connaissait suffisamment pour dire je
suis assez indépendant d'esprit pour le
dire donc c'est pas le sujet le modèle
économique qui s'est fait que les
grandes marches faisaient plutôt sur les
fruits et légumes que sur les grands
produits de grande consommation parce
que là ils avaient moins de capacité à
négocier avec des grands groupes ce que
vous avez besoin de certaine marque dans
les dans les grandes surfaces et donc
vous êtes moins en situation de force
alors on pouvait c'est comme ça que
c'est construit l'équilibre économique
vous voyez c'est ça le sujet principal
et donc on a besoin d'un modèle
économique qui pense différemment les
choses et donc il me semble que plutôt
que de dire on va aller chercher à
l'extérieur des frontières on peut
essayer de se dire dans ce moment
inflationniste parce que je trouve
monsieur Leclerc très pro a demandé les
baisses quand il était très lent à
pratiquer les hausses au moment où il y
avait des hausses comment ça se passe
pour être concret sur un produit je fais
juste un exemple
vous produisez vous mettez dans une
bouteille en verre ou en plastique même
si on a la nécessité de sortir du
plastique mettez une dans une bouteille
en verre le verre vous l'avez pas acheté
au moment où il est mis en marché
aujourd'hui vous l'avez acheté il y a 6
mois donc le prix du verre que vous
vendez aujourd'hui
s'il y a plus d'unités agroalimentaire
s'il y a plus d'usine agroalimentaire il
y aura plus agriculteurs parce qu'au
bout il faut bien que les produits
soient transformés en France on va pas
envoyer nos produits dans des pays tiers
pour les transports comment ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on fait sur certains produits
pas surtout parce que sur les chips par
exemple sur un serpent sur les chiffres
sous certaines céréales on le fait mais
globalement sur un certain nombre sur
les fruits et légumes sur la sur la
viande et sur le lait on transforme dans
notre pays quand même
sur le lait il y a un peu de
transformation quand vous voyez toute la
variété des yaourts que vous avez dans
un supermarché il y a un tout petit peu
de transformation sur les c'est pas que
du lait hein
c'est c'est avec les phénomènes de
sécheresse qui se multiplient quand on
voit ce qui se passe déjà dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales dans l'Hérault dans
le Var je crois aussi on se dit que
forcément cet été les fruits et les
légumes en France vont exploser alors
difficile de le dire à date mais si la
situation se prolongée se d'autant que
nous ne sommes pas les seuls concernés
parce que vous l'avez vu les Espagnols
sont bien plus concernés que nous et on
sait bien à quel point
la saisonnalité des fruits et légumes et
le prix des fruits et légumes et
dépendant jamais été ça dépend
honnêtement objectivement ça ne date pas
de cette année donc adapt difficile d'y
répondre mais évidemment on a une
vigilance sur un certain nombre de
fruits je pense chez nectarine ou le
gros la grosse zone de production et
dans les départements vous venez de
citer et pour le coup là viendra pas
rattraper les autres mais vous dites pas
que là avec la sécheresse dont on parle
quasiment maintenant chaque année il va
y avoir un problème de prix et de plus
en plus régulièrement faire une deuxième
partie de réponse c'est qu'après dans
notre question de souveraineté c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin de d'accompagner
des agriculteurs dans les transitions il
faut pas que chaque année ou tous les
deux ans soient dans un système qui
risque de collapser si vous permettez
cette expression parce qu'il y aurait de
la sécheresse et qui ferait des
fluctuations de prix trop loin parce que
les flucturation de prix trop grande
c'est bon pour personne quand c'est bon
on croit que c'est bon pour les
producteurs mais à la fin ça finit que
généralement les prises castigeur donc
ça ne stabilise pas un marché on a
besoin de stabiliser donc c'est là qu'on
a besoin de penser dans chaque
territoire quels sont les moyens pour
améliorer la résilience au choc
climatique ici pas assez d'eau dans le
Nord il y a trop d'eau déjà on peut pas
planter les pommes de terre donc
dérèglement climatique il pose une
obligation de transition un peu
accélérée même si c'est très difficile
de faire des transitions là mais sur la
question des prix est-ce qu'on peut
avoir des des stabilisateurs
le meilleur là-haut c'est à la baisse il
me semble que le système qui est de
résilience c'est important pour les
agriculteurs alors moi je pense que le
meilleur stabilisateur au fond c'est la
contractualisation c'est une forme de
stabilisation la contractualisation vous
m'aidez d'accord sur un volume et vous
mettez d'accord sur un pluriel avec des
ajustements ça permet à tout le monde de
pouvoir investir en conscience parce que
quand vous êtes agriculteur si vous avez
un contrat sur 3 à 5 ans ça vous permet
de savoir la visibilité même s'il y a
des fluctuations je pense que la
contractualisation et c'est ce à quoi
pousse égale donc il y a un certain
nombre de secteurs dans lequel on a
cette contractualisation c'est un
élément de stabilisation je pense que
c'est le meilleur stabilisateur parce
que pour les consommateurs mais aussi
pour les industries agroalimentaires
pour la distribution parce que ça leur
assure
l'approvisionnement et pour les
producteurs évidemment parce que ça leur
assure à la fois la quantité qui
pourront livrer et par ailleurs une
forme de stabilisation parce que du côté
des consommateurs il y a pas aussi
peut-être besoin d'une sorte de de
pédagogie d'un travail de pédagogie on
le voit
avec Karine en parler tout à l'heure il
y a le ministre du Budget qui qui lance
un site ayant pour vos impôts en
expliquant combien ça coûte en réalité
un soin
une opération à l'hôpital qui coûte
monstrueusement cher aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'il faut pas aussi expliquer aux
Français combien coûtent réellement une
tomate pour un producteur et qu'il faut
éviter d'avoir cette espèce de vision
complètement floutée à cause des des
pratiques de la grande distribution
mais effectivement dans les années 50-60
la part de l'alimentation était bien
plus importante au budget qu'aujourd'hui
on est entre 13 et 16% selon la nature
de revenus quand on était plutôt à 25
ans à la vérité je me suis toujours pour
moi-même du temple pédagogique parce
qu'on a l'impression que les gens
comprennent pas et qu'il faudrait leur
expliquer avec de la pédagogie française
parfois on nous fait le reproche le
gouvernement si vous faites de la
pédagogie vous prenez les gens pour des
imbéciles ce qui est pas mon tempérament
des enfants
on a besoin c'est que il me semble que
François Bayrou nous explique qu'on a
pas fait suffisamment de pédagogie sur
la réforme c'est un mot qui était très
utilisé
à nous principalement je vois bien que
vous essayez de me taquiner mais
j'aurais du mal à le faire mais je
reviens à notre affaire de pédagogie
reprenons le mot on a besoin de mieux
expliquer comment se construisent les
prix on a besoin de mieux expliquer en
quoi l'acte d'achat d'un produit
français c'est un acte de souveraineté
au final parce que quand vous n'êtes pas
l'agriculteurs et vous n'êtes plus vous
n'êtes plus capable de vous nourrir vous
vous mettez dans les mains des autres
confère ce qui se passe avec la guerre
en Ukraine et Monsieur Poutine dont
dépendent beaucoup de pays pour se
nourrir et pour avoir des céréales
parfois parce qu'ils ont choisi parfois
parce qu'ils peuvent pas faire autrement
parce qu'ils ont ils ont un mauvais clim
puis un deuxième sujet dans cette
question la pédagogie il faut que
nous-mêmes on donne l'exemple nous état
c'est-à-dire que les circuits courts les
produits bio il faut qu'on c'est
d'ailleurs c'est la décision qui a été
prise par la première ministre faut
qu'on fasse en sorte que à l'école ça
c'est plutôt les collectivités que dans
les grands services comme c'est beaucoup
on l'a pas atteint aujourd'hui les
objectifs qui avaient été 20% de tes 20
et 20% dans les centaines on en est très
loin on est entre 6 et 10%. donc on est
assez loin mais deux fois moins mais ça
marche pas que ça marche pas donc on a
besoin d'accélérer et le mieux pour
accélérer ce qu'il y a une part c'est
les collectivités et elles peuvent être
dans des sujets budgétaires mais
certaines le font mais il y a une
deuxième part c'est l'état exemplaire et
donc le travail que nous allons faire là
dans les semaines qui viennent c'est de
dire dans la commande publique quand
vous intégrez des produits de circuit
court et des produits locaux vous faites
vous-même une pédagogie par la preuve de
votre capacité à faire
on va demander aux administrations de
répondre aux objectifs des gamines très
clairement dans les semaines dans la
moitié qui viennent la meilleure
pédagogie c'est celle de la vérité
est-ce qu'on doit dire aux gens que les
prix des produits alimentaires ne
baisseront pas peut-être que l'inflation
va se tasser mais il y aura pas de
déflation les prix ne baisseront pas ou
bien au contraire vous pouvez leur dire
si si l'année prochaine les prix seront
moins élevés il y a une partie des prix
sans doute qui vont baisser honnêtement
sur un certain nombre de produits qui
sont liés qui sont liés aux emballages
oui oui non il y a un certain nombre de
prix qui peuvent baisser quand vous avez
beaucoup d'emballages et que les
emballages sont une partie du prix de la
monnaiement important quand c'est du
produit brut qui est quand c'est du
produit comme les céréales si les
engrais baisse les céréales logiquement
devrait baisser dans un marché mondial
qui serait normal mais est-ce que ça se
retrouve dans les magasins pour les
logiques oui alors après est-ce qu'on
revient attendez est-ce qu'on revient
quand vous avez une poussée
inflationniste comme celle-là
historiquement vous redescendez pas
jamais jamais mais ni pour les salaires
ni pour les couleurs oui mais
l'important c'est la trajectoire la
trajectoire c'est une stabilisation et
la deuxième trajectoire c'est comme une
baisse relative par rapport à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui parce que si on voit
bien que sur les céréales on va assister
à un moment à une forme de décrue est-ce
qu'il faut faire une pause dans les
normes enfin on a cru comprendre et
beaucoup d'explications derrière pour
nous dire qu'on avait rien compris que
pédagogie un moment un moment
envie renon mental était tellement
contraignante compris ce qui est soit
d'être peu compétitif soit de poser un
problème à certains noms de métiers
comme les agriculteurs qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire ou qu'est-ce que les autres
ne font pas qu'on fait ou qu'est-ce qui
qu'on devrait faire par rapport à ce
qu'a dit le président de la République
en particulier jeudi dernier alors
reprenons les mots et les éléments mais
je n'ai pas citer les mots pour mot
je sens que non mais j'essayais pas une
pause dans les normes environnementale
c'est-à-dire qu'il a demandé à ce qu'on
en rajoute pas qu'on applique celle qui
existe et qu'on en rajoute déjà on a un
sujet qui s'appelle le pacte vert qui
était une décision européenne qui est
une décision qui vise à la neutralité
carbone en 2050 est-ce qu'on est tous
d'accord là-dessus je pense que oui on
est ce qu'on est tous d'accord sur les
objectifs de l'accord de Paris
il me semble que oui globalement nous
sommes d'accord donc si on arrive
simplement à faire ça on aura gagné la
partie pour ce qui est attendez ce
message je vous explique ça a des
conséquences par exemple je vais vous
donner juste un exemple sur la
réglementation des logements ce qu'on
appelle la réglementation 20 20 sur des
acronymes en France ça s'appelle
réglementation sur les normes de
logement nature de l'isolant isolant
autorisé en quoi ça qu'est-ce qu'on
accepte comme consommation par mètre
carré vous allez pas faire une erreur
une R22 une R23 on a besoin pour que se
construire et des filières industrielles
d'avoir des trajectoires sinon c'est pas
la peine de parler de planification la
planification elle souffre un objectif
neutralité pour prendre cet exemple
neutralité carbone il y a des textes qui
sont en train d'être déclinés soit au
niveau national soit au niveau européen
finissons de décliner ces textes et si
nous arrivons déjà à ça on sera le
continent le plus exemplaire et celui
qui répondra aux objectifs de l'accord
de Paris donc parfois il nous même
politique en sommes responsable je pense
collectivement c'est on pense que en
produisant la norme on produit des
effets déjà il faut qu'on arrive à
obtenir nos effets je vous donne la
question que je viens d'évoquer des
Galim on a dit 35% de produits locaux ou
circuit ou bio on y est pas bah au lieu
de mettre 75%, peut-être qu'on pourrait
être à 50 et quand on aura fait 50 on en
reparlera vous voyez c'est ça la
question c'est cette espèce de course
à la norme que parfois on produit pour
répondre à une émotion du moment etc
elle produit pas des résultats et donc
on a besoin sauf que peut-être que la
nature va aller beaucoup plus vite que
les normes que dont vous parlez
peut-être que cet été on aura encore des
mégafeux et que et que la la le
rationnellement
donc c'est quand même assez étonnant ce
message qu'on voit le chef de l'État en
disant faisons une pause qu'allons-nous
on en fait assez comme ça est-ce que
est-ce que vous ce message vous êtes à
l'aise avec si on était un peu modeste
collectivement c'est les défis qu'on a
devant nous climatiques c'est des défis
pour des siècles contenus de ce qui
s'est passé et donc penser qu'on va
résoudre par une réglementation
supplémentaire en 2023 les feux de 2023
attendez l'anticipons
essayons de pas caricaturer ce qu'on se
dit les uns les autres ni vous ni moi
reprenons les feux on équipe mieux
Gérald Darmanin a annoncé sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
la première ministre son équipe mieux
pour lutter contre les incendies on met
150 millions d'euros pour renouveler le
patrimoine ici pardon quand on plante un
arbre un chêne il y en a pour 100 ans
alors vous pouvez me raconter ce que
vous voulez on peut faire toutes les
normes pour faire pousser les chaînes en
tirant dessus ça va pas marcher notre
affaire donc on a besoin si on veut
faire on a besoin de renouveler 30 %
si on veut des carboner le logement on a
besoin d'en couper pour le stocker pour
éviter de faire du ciment qui lui-même
oui produit c'est un tout petit peu
compliqué notre affaire oui on a besoin
quand vous mettez des arbres dans la
charpente de Notre-Dame vous les mettez
pour des siècles et alors donc vous
stocker du carbone non mais du coup
c'est très intéressant ça veut dire que
peut-être il y a une partie des terres
agricoles où il y a beaucoup de
d'élevage qui pourrait être réduites
pour mettre des forêts à la place oui
alors vous allez vous
c'est c'est des idées de climatoologue
non mais que dans certains cas ce soit
la réponse mais pardon vous allez dans
les Pyrénées-Orientales il y a de
l'élevage vous allez pas faire pousser
un arbre c'est où l'élevage est un peu
de d'herbe mais est-ce qu'on peut
enlever les climatologue dit ça mais
pardon d'autre disent que dans les
prairies il y a des la biodiversité qui
est très riche donc il va si on pouvait
essayer de trouver pas des caricatures
j'ai pas dit que vous aviez dit ça mais
au fond des compromis sur ces sujets là
c'est pas on va transformer tous les
sujets en arbre on va pas planter des
plantes
je les dis moi-même parce que je sens
que c'est un sujet très important mais
il faut qu'on accepte de se dire on a
des sujets on n'est pas là pour répondre
seulement à l'immédiateté incendie 2023
on est pour penser qu'il y aura moins
faire en sorte qu'il y a moins d'incendu
en 2050 ça s'adresse à qui ce message le
côté faisons déjà ce qu'on a dit qu'on
ferait et non pas non en rajoutant pas
président de la République a dit deux
choses il a dit ah il faut déjà qu'on
la norme ne produit pas non non mais
c'est pas pour faire je sens que vous
allez vous avez l'impression que
j'essaie de faire de la pédagogie je
suis un peu idiote non c'est moi qui
m'exprime mal que ça vous va mieux comme
ça la norme ne produit pas le résultat
forcément donc on a déjà besoin de
s'assurer que la norme que nous
produisons elle produit le résultat que
nous voulons c'est quand même c'est
quand même pas compliqué d'arriver à
faire ça déjà et une fois qu'on aura
fait ça peuvent se reposer des questions
et donc le message c'est un message
collectif de nous croyons pas quand on a
une idée parfois en France que la norme
elle règle le problème c'est je vais
interdire toutes les passoires
thermiques oui sauf que il faut une
trajectoire il faut des financements il
faut de la planification et si demain
matin je veux dire c'est plus les EF
mais c'est les CD ok une fois que j'ai
dit ça est-ce que j'ai fait avancer un
objectif c'est un peu facile il faut
l'organiser mais et donc c'est ça ce que
je veux dire et donc sur la question
forestière c'est pareil on a besoin non
seulement de penser c'est des étés les
incendies de forêts mais on a besoin de
renouveler sans doute 30 à 40% de la
forêt française quand tu as 40% la forêt
française faut des bras faut des plans
faut du temps et donc il va falloir
qu'on accepte aussi ça parce que si on
n'est pas capable de se dire c'est sous
il y a de l'urgence mais en même temps
il faut être modeste à l'échelle de la
de la vie humaine on essaie de faire le
chemin qu'on a à faire sur les ou sur le
reste alors à ce moment-là on fait un
défaut on fait du Yaka faucon et on
avance pas
France Inter
[Musique]
Thomas negaro
un bon quart d'heure avec nous également
dans question politique on a évoqué les
politiques on a évoqué les consommateurs
jamais qu'on s'arrête maintenant sur les
agriculteurs est-ce que vous diriez un
jeune agriculteur qui veut se lancer
aujourd'hui que c'est un peu inconscient
face aux incertitudes économiques aux
incertitudes climatiques aussi de se
lancer dans cette belle profession je ne
dirai jamais à quelqu'un qui a un rêve
et qui a un projet quel que soit le
sujet agriculture ou pas de ne pas se
lancer dans et simplement mon exigence
que moi comme une liste de l'agriculture
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il soit le
mieux armée possible dans le moment
qu'on traverse qui est un moment de
grande dérèglement et pour l'agriculture
particulièrement grande dérèglement des
règlements géopolitiques qui font des
fluctuations de prix des règlements
économiques on vient d'en parler
dérèglements climatiques enfin le tout
cumulé peut faire beaucoup et donner le
sentiment de quoi on a besoin et ça va
être l'objet c'est l'objet du travail
que nous ont pour préparer la loi
d'orientation c'est d'essayer de mieux
armer les agriculteurs pour leur faire
face à ces défis alors
alors on a du mal à voir quelle est la
vision de l'exécutif aujourd'hui sur
l'agriculture de demain est-ce que c'est
une agriculture de rendement est-ce que
c'est une agriculture écologiste et si
on était pas dans la caricature et que
on disait que tu risques on pose la
question
d'agriculture si on disait qu'il y a pas
une agriculture mais des agriculteurs il
y a des endroits on va faire plutôt de
l'élevage qui a des endroits on fera
plutôt du maraîchage parce que ça s'y
prête parce qu'il y a accès à l'eau
qu'il y a des endroits où peut-être on
fera plutôt de la grande culture parce
que c'est la vocation naturelle de ces
territoires de faire de la grande
culture c'est ça qu'on a besoin ce qu'on
a besoin en revanche de construire c'est
de se dire qu'il y a pas un territoire
et une agriculture en France qui ne va
pas être soumise au contraire du
dérèglement climatique et donc on a
besoin d'engager les agriculteurs et en
particulier les jeunes et pas que les
jeunes sur c'est quoi votre modèle
sous dérèglement climatiques je reprends
les cas de l'élevage parce que du coup
ça veut dire c'est quoi le modèle est-ce
que dans la ce qu'on dirait un
territoire ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'agriculture conventionnelle est-ce que
par exemple ça fait partie des modèles
qui continueront à exister mais ça fait
partie des modèles qui peuvent qui
peuvent exister oui bien sûr mais on va
je reprends j'allais prolonger mais ça
va répondre à votre question vous avez
un modèle qu'on vante les vertus en
France et a juste titre qui est le
modèle d'élevage extensifs dans le
Massif Central bon quel est le problème
sur cet élevage c'est que si vous avez
des épisodes comme 2022 trop répétitifs
vous allez avoir un sujet d'accès au
fourrage or ce modèle il est vertueux
pour lutter contre les incendies parce
que il est vertu en terme de production
et de de qualité de la production qui
est faite il est vertu en termes de
biodiversité enfin il est vertueux a
bien des enseignes et dans l'espace
public il est plutôt vanté comment on
fait en sorte que on gère mieux la
contrainte de l'accès au fourrage est-ce
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des bâtiments
pour répondre concrètement c'est
l'agriculture conventionnelle est-ce
qu'il faut qu'ils aient des bâtiments
plus grands pour que les années où il y
a beaucoup de fourrage ils ont stockent
plus pour passer les mauvaises années
est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils puissent avoir
accès à la culture qui leur permettent
de diversifier l'alimentation de leur
bêta parce qu'on leur demande par
ailleurs d'être autonome pour pas que
vienne du soja venant du Brésil c'est ça
qui va falloir qu'on fasse territoire
par territoire l'agriculture
conventionnelle elle-même fait sa
transition
chacun doit faire le commentaire vous
trouvez qu'ils font leur transition par
exemple vous trouvez qu'ils sont moins
consommateurs en eau qu'ils essaient de
trouver des solutions je croise et je
crois pas croiser un échantillon qui
soit un échantillon
plus avancé que les autres ils ont tout
à fait conscience des sujets d'eau il
suffit de regarder d'ailleurs dès qu'on
lance des appels à manifestation de
l'Intérêt ou d'un peine investissement
pour avoir des des
systèmes d'irrigation qui sont beaucoup
plus économano il se jette dessus
d'ailleurs ils le savent parce que à la
vérité quand vous êtes dans une zone
comme la mienne dans le hacher vous avez
un quota qui est déterminé en fonction
du niveau de la nappe et ils savent
qu'il dépasseront pas le quota donc ils
sont en train de faire évoluer les
pratiques alors on peut dire c'est trop
lent moi mon sujet c'est d'engager les
transitions parce que on peut pas se
faire les accélérer par exemple en
limitant l'accès à l'eau mais parce que
l'eau
doit faire des efforts mais pas les
agriculteurs non mais pardon dans un
certain nombre de cas de toute façon
excusez-moi de faire une phrase qui est
un peu idiote je la préviens tout de
suite quand il y a plus d'eau il y a
plus d'eau donc quand il y a des mesures
de résumé quand il y a plus d'eau
parce que je veux dire par là c'est que
les agricules quand c'est pas seulement
une trajectoire à moyen long terme
chaque année il y a des mesures de
restriction qui sont faites où on réduit
l'utilisation donc le système lui-même
est en train de se réguler par ce motif
là quand vous avez des projets
non c'est pas ce que je dis quand on est
sur un sujet comme sainte Soline par
exemple on est sur un sujet où on
demande aux agriculteurs de réduire d'un
tiers leur consommation de planter des
de faire évoluer un certain nombre
d'assolement donc c'est bien le sujet
qu'on a devant donc c'est moins d'eau à
l'hectare consommé donc c'est sobriété à
l'hectare mais il y a des territoires
aujourd'hui qui vont avoir besoin d'eau
qui n'en avait pas besoin ailleurs donc
c'est que par la sobriété qu'on y
arrivera à notre affaire deuxièmement
c'est d'avoir des variétés qui la plus
économie nous les variétés de maïs qu'on
est aujourd'hui et consomment 30% de
moins d'eau que il y a 30 ans bon donc
on a besoin de faire de la recherche
véritable on a besoin par ailleurs
d'avoir du matériel qui soit plus
économe quand vous passez d'un système
classique un système au bout à goutte ou
réduisez de 30 à 50 % votre consommation
donc c'est tout ce chemin-là qu'il faut
faire qu'on accompagne au travers qu'on
a accompagné d'abord au travers de
France relance et maintenant au travers
de France il y a une filière qui est
très en colère c'est la filière bio
aujourd'hui considant que vous l'avez
pas suffisamment soutenu 10 millions ça
représente 166 euros par exploitation à
ce que j'ai pu lire en disant que
c'était vraiment pas assez ils
demandaient 800 millions je crois 10
millions 800 millions est-ce que vous
considérez effectivement que là il y a
peut-être eu assez d'État on avait
besoin de de qualifier de documenter je
ferai des annonces le mercredi prochain
autour de quoi d'abord d'un plan
d'urgence pour mieux soutenir la filière
qui est en grande difficulté
deuxièmement mais je l'annoncerai
mercredi il faut que j'ai fait le tout
pardon je suis désolé mais
je sors
plus que 100 millions pardon il y a
plusieurs globalement ça sera plus que
100 millions pourquoi parce qu'on va
avoir à la fois le plan d' urgence on va
avoir la commande publique
quelle est la crise qu'on a sur le bio
c'est une crise de baisse de
consommation on a eu un moment une crise
d'offre on disait il y a pas assez de
producteur bio ça vient tous les pays
européens
alors résultat les on pourrait dire
d'ailleurs et le mettre à notre crédit
qu'on est quand même un pays qui a
plutôt progressé alors on nous dira que
c'est pas assez je connais par cœur tous
les grèves qui nous sont faits mais on a
plutôt avancé on a doublé les surfaces
et je et ça jointes avec le quinquennat
François Hollande donc je tire pas les
marrons du feu je dis juste qu'on a
plutôt progressé dans ce pays on a
doublé les surfaces résultat des courses
on a une crise liés à l'inflation qui
est il y a une baisse de consommation
qui est très puissante bon donc crise
d'urgence on a besoin de moyens
urgence aussi on sait que la seule
baisse de consommation qu'on a dans la
grande surface
si simplement on atteignait les
objectifs des gamins on va essayer de
faire ça parce que ça c'est pour le coup
ça fait quoi l'affaire de la
contractualisation c'est une moyen de
stabiliser une offre quand vous savez
que vous allez alimenter la cantine le
collège le lycée etc vous savez que vous
en avez pour plusieurs années parce que
ça a marché public bon donc c'est mieux
de faire comme ça donc ça c'est un
deuxième volet juste une question de
curiosité et gaming français c'est du
burger facilement c'est du bleu général
mais c'est du boulot non mais on vit oui
d'accord on vit dans un espace quand
vous êtes sur circuit court et bio on
peut avoir quand même la pensée que
globalement c'est plutôt du bio français
qui soit dès lors qu'on a une offre
française il me semble que c'est plutôt
comme ça que ça se passe après on peut
aussi décider qu'on vit sur une île et
qu'on a pas de voisins européens
européen la question sur le bio c'est
plutôt une question de d'avoir une
demande qui soit poussée et le bio
français il trouvera sa place d'ailleurs
non et puis un troisième sujet sur le
bureau et c'est la troisième volet pour
moi c'est auquel je tiens
particulièrement sur ça je le dis c'est
la question de la communication on a
besoin de repositionner le bio comme un
produit de qualité qui est le plus
abouti en termes de pratique et en même
temps c'est un produit de proximité et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis
2020-2021 Chris covid c'est que les gens
se sont beaucoup retournés vers les
circuits courts d'ailleurs les grandes
enseignes sont allés beaucoup sur les
circuits courts les circuits de
proximité que ce soit bio ou pas bio et
donc il y a une forme de concurrence
alors c'est la vie on va pas faire de
grief au consommateurs qui s'est noué au
moment de la crise covid je savais que
tout le monde allait
dans les marchés parce que c'était les
lieux d'abord plutôt à l'extérieur et
deux il y avait une forme de distance
qu'on pouvait pas parcourir donc
nécessité faisant loi et peut-être qu'on
a pas bien vu ça à l'époque et tout le
monde hein je veux dire donc je fais pas
grève donc on a besoin de reconstruire
l'image du bio comme Son Excellence et
en même temps comme un produit de
proximité clairement oui vous parlez
tout à l'heure de de l'aide pour la
transition écologique il y a quand même
un gros sujet avec les pesticides votre
décision là de demander à l'agence de
nationale de sécurité alimentaire de
revenir sur l'interdiction du S métaux
la chlore métola clore merci
a fait a fait beaucoup de bruit
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en fait que
aider les agriculteurs à cette
transition c'est sans cesse repousser
les délais ou est-ce que est-ce qu'il y
a autre chose que
un herbicide
qui détruit enfin qui polluent
sérieusement les nappes phréatiques on
retrouve des résidus dans un certain
nombre de
potentiel potentiellement donc attendez
on supprime pourquoi
une citation dans laquelle je mets en
cause la vie de lances et je dis pas que
c'est la trajectoire vers laquelle on va
je vous mets au défi
la polémique est née de quoi elle est
née du fait qu'au niveau européen nous
avons une décision qui est attendue pour
le 25 mai et que j'estimé alors j'ai
franchi un rubiconde démentiel enfin je
sens que j'ai été révolutionnaire j'ai
dit 25 mars 25 mai si on attendait le 25
mai
j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir été
révolutionnaire j'ai juste dit on attend
une décision de lève ça la semaine
prochaine enfin dans 10 jours qui va
dire j'interdis ou pas et théoriquement
dont on me dit qu'elle va être dans le
même sens que l'on sait c'est ce que
disent les premiers éléments de ça bon
bah très bien mais si jamais les chats
dit mais dire au niveau européen sauf en
France puisque nous nous aurions pris
notre décision on n'interdit pas parce
qu'on n'a pas la même analyse qu'est-ce
qu'on fait vous voyez ce que je veux
dire donc jamais vous m'avez entendu
parce que moi je pense qu'il faut jamais
remettre en cause la science parce que
ce que remis en cause la science c'est
les mêmes est-ce que vous m'avez entendu
pourquoi les remettre en question
non non il y a pas de problème
de décaler leur avis quel intérêt
excusez-moi
d'anticiper madame gatine pardon
excusez-moi je connais un peu le dossier
c'est 6 mois plus 18 mois donc de toute
façon c'est
entre 18 et 24 mois peut-être qu'on peut
attendre d'avoir une décision européenne
pour la qualifier au même niveau au
niveau européen mais je vois bien que ça
ça nourrit des polémiques un peu facile
mais moi je ne je et par ailleurs qu'en
lançaise prend d'autres décisions il y a
un certain nombre d'autres gens qui sont
parfois des gens qui sont des
adversaires politiques quand il s'agit
de confiner les volailles on dit il faut
plus confiner les volailles je dirais
oui mais c'est la demande de lances bien
non mais il faut s'affranchir de la
demande de lancer alors c'est à la carte
ou c'est pas la carte allez une question
politique
pour revenir sur la réforme des
retraites et le report à 64 ans
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans la majorité on
fait de l'obstruction on laisse la vie
démocratique se dérouler
ça serait quand même cocasse alors c'est
l'ancien ministre des relations qui
parle du Parlement avec le Parlement qui
parle serait quand même cocasse que
parce qu'on y aurait 50 100 ou 200
amendements quand d'autres on en ont
fait 20 ou 30000 on vient de nous faire
leurs proches mais ça dépend des
amendements ou c'est juste pour planter
le texte oui non mais pardon est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut respecter aussi le
Parlement dans cette prérogative je sais
je sais pas ce que il faut décideront
les grosses acceptons quel débat 2e
départ mais moi j'ai aucun problème avec
le débat j'ai pas peur mais j'ai pas
peur j'ai compris
moi vous m'avez pas entendu dire il y a
20000 amendements c'est l'obstruction je
vais pas me rentrer dans le terrain et
me faire intoxiqué par ce qu'il dit si
on a 300 c'est l'obstruction attendez il
faut que les gens soient cohérent dans
la vie il y a des gens qui ont fait
l'obstruction sur ce texte qui ont
empêché qu'on aille au vote d'ailleurs à
l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'on était
déjà deux semaines et demi ou trois
semaines de débat et il en restait 25000
et ils viennent maintenant vous faire la
leçon parce qu'il y en a il y en a il y
en a qui
dans la majorité je pose par contre une
deuxième question c'est moi je suis
aussi respectueux de la Constitution il
y a je trouve que dans la Constitution
il y a un article qui s'appelle
l'article 40 ah oui lequel article 40
dit qu'on peut pas faire un texte il va
dans le parle pas dans le même pas dans
le sens non pas du tout qui revient sur
non pas du tout ça c'est la question
c'est la question de référendum
l'article 40 il dit on ne peut pas faire
un texte sauf s'il est le gouvernement
qui augmente les charges alors ce texte
là il fait quoi et ben alors si on
l'utilise il y a pas de débat mais en
tout cas c'est une question qu'on peut
poser parce qu'en fait c'est le c'est le
président de la commission des finances
Eric bon parce que à la vérité on est en
train de dire aux gens qu'on fait un
test qui pourrait être qui serait sans
doute censuré je ne préjugue pas des
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
parce que ça sera un texte qui engage
une dépense supplémentaire sans que
l'État est levé le gage donc il faut
tout engager dans ce domaine hein on
fasse pas d'obstruction 2 qu'on puisse
accepter qu'il y ait du débat et donc
des amendements trois qu'on respecte
aussi la Constitution et moi je fais pas
de je passe pas de l'article 39 à
l'article 41 il y a un article s'appelle
l'article 40
mais pas du tout
non mais aucun ne me dérange mais
simplement est-ce qu'on pourrait
on a commencé avec le fait qu'il fallait
respecter un certain nombre de principes
républicains si jamais vous dites on
peut faire toutes les dépenses qu'on
veut on va avoir que des pelles à 15 ou
20 milliards mais qui paye au bout mais
sur la fin c'est les Français ça dépend
je vais vous dire c'est gager sur les
tabacs
si c'est gagé sur les tabac je crois que
ça fait un paquet de cigarettes à 800 ou
900 euros
de qui se moque-t-on des gens qui dans
la rue nous diraient
selon vous elle peut passer ou pas parce
que c'est quand même qui nous intéresse
j'en sais rien mais je pense que
à vrai dire au-delà du débat initial que
nous avons eu on a un débat de gentil
propose de revenir sont sur une réforme
sans répondre à la question de base sur
lesquelles sans doute je vais me déguger
nous n'avons pas fait assez de pédagogie
qui est comme en équilibre le système de
retraite
on peut voter on peut faire des
amendements on peut appliquer l'article
40 on peut aussi faire comme on voyait
je veux dire et nous on peut respecter
la démocratie les institutions c'est de
respecter les règles et nous on peut
rendre l'antenne merci Marc merci
beaucoup on se retrouve dimanche
prochain pour un nouveau numéro 2
question politique
[Musique]